qué harías si fueras mil veces más
valiente
valiente pregunto un coach en una sesión
en la que yo estaba y si bien esa
pregunta no era para mí
las respuestas que me di hizo que
rodarán lágrimas por mis mejillas
primero porque me di cuenta
que era muy infeliz
me di cuenta que estaba muy insatisfecha
con lo que pasaba en ese momento en mi
vida
me vi presa de miedo
dejando pasar oportunidades
que no pensaba en ese momento que fueran
para mí
que posiblemente eran para otros no para
mí
también esa noche
lloré porque me di cuenta que la vida
son dos raticos y yo ya me había gastado
uno
entonces empecé a pensar qué voy a hacer
con el ratico que me queda cómo lo voy a
emplear
y esa noche recordé la primera entre la
primera charla de trabajo que yo tuve la
primera reunión que tuve en mi primer
trabajo
fue con un médico
qué me dice miren niña yo
tengo 60 años parezco de 85
porque tengo un cáncer avanzado
pero yo no me quiero ir de este mundo
sin llevarme todo lo que sé sin llevarme
todo mi conocimiento porque si yo me voy
llevándome todo lo que lo que tengo en
la cabeza me paso por este mundo no
tendría sentido
así que ese pediatra escribió dos libros
uno para mamás y otro para médicos y
después de eso se fue en paz yo me
acordé de esa conversación esa noche
porque yo amo el conocimiento
vamos a aprender cómo estudiar pero
también en algunos momentos he pensado y
todo eso que yo estudio sino lo comparto
qué sentido tiene para qué
razón por la cual esa noche pensé que mi
propósito de vida estaba por ese camino
que mi propósito de vida tenía que ver
con ayudar a otras personas a aprender
no con enseñar me gusta más ayudar a
aprender
esa noche
también pensé
que ya no quería trabajar más para nadie
y a pesar de que llevaba haciendo por 18
años una exitosa estratega de mercadeo
para empresas del sector financiero no
era feliz y ya no quería trabajar más
para nadie así que esa noche decidí
entrar en el mar del emprendimiento
y navegar y zambullirme y bucear en el
mar del emprendimiento
desde ese entonces soy coach
obviamente estudie muchísimo para llegar
a ello soy coach relacional ustedes me
preguntaran qué significa eso
básicamente lo que yo hago es acompañar
a empresas
a que fluyan a través de que las
habilidades de relacionamiento de las
habilidades gerenciales que son las
habilidades del siglo 21 y acompañar a
esas personas que trabajan en esas
empresas a que confluyan para que para
que las empresas salgan adelante
desde ese entonces hasta hoy
tengo miedo
todos los días de mi vida tengo miedo
todos los días de mi vida trabajo con
miedo
como todos los emprendedores
no importa a qué nos dediquemos
no importa si trabajamos en empresas del
sector masivo en empresas del sector
real en la empresa de servicio cuántos
años llevamos de experiencia en que
elaboren qué campos nos desempeñamos
todos tenemos miedo
y por eso hoy quiero hablar de emprender
con miedo
porque todos aquellos que son
emprendedores de cualquier proyecto
emprendedores de una familia de
emprendedores de una empresa
emprendedores de una idea saben que
todos los días nos levantamos en
incertidumbre y la incertidumbre produce
miedo
pero de eso no se habla
cuando nos estamos preparando en la
universidad nos enseñan finanzas nos
enseñan
tecnología nos enseñan procesos
procedimientos pero jamás nos dan clase
de miedo avanzado sí o no
nunca tuvimos incertidumbre profunda en
la universidad
no existe parece que no existiera y
resulta que el miedo está ahí siempre
para todos nosotros en cada decisión que
tomemos de vida
y hoy lo que yo quiero hacer con ustedes
es reivindicar el miedo
reivindicar el miedo miren
paradójicamente cuando uno busca en
google
emprender sin miedo
hay 20 millones 900 mil resultados que
hablan de vencer el miedo superar el
miedo derrotar el miedo libérate del
miedo
emprender con miedo no tiene ningún
resultado
no tiene ningún resultado efectivo en la
búsqueda
pero es que es nuestra condición humana
la que nos lleva a que el miedo siempre
esté presente y para qué sirve el miedo
para que el miedo como lo dice norberto
lewis es una alerta es como un testigo
el testigo de la gasolina que se prende
cuando nosotros evidenciamos que hay una
desproporción muy grande entre una
amenaza que sentimos y los recursos con
los que contamos o sentimos que contamos
para combatirla en ese momento se prende
el testigo en ese momento se prende la
alerta para decirnos ojo hay que tomar
decisiones hay que avanzar o hay que
retroceder hay que encontrar un camino
el miedo está ahí para ayudarnos también
miren hace poco hablaba con un
emprendedor que me decía me contaba tuve
monté un restaurante
y no tuve miedo entonces monté el
segundo y no tuve miedo monté el tercero
monte el cuarto monte el quinto al sexto
me quedé
no se le prendió el testigo de la
gasolina nunca no se le prendió el
testigo del miedo nunca
el miedo está ahí para alertarnos y esa
es su luz
sin embargo por supuesto como todas las
emociones tiene sombras el miedo también
tiene una sombra la sombra del miedo
tiene que ver con la parálisis que nos
puede producir
miren hay algo súper importante ahí y es
que nosotros cuando estamos frente a una
por ejemplo a un león
en la selva dispuesto a devorar nos
generamos en el cuerpo una cantidad de
reacciones
instintivas como el aumento de la
presión arterial como la disminución de
la sangre en la cabeza no vimos no vemos
no entendemos claramente por qué porque
la sangre está en nuestros en nuestras
extremidades para huir para correr para
de alguna manera superar esa amenaza que
tenemos enfrente las funciones vitales
se interrumpen no vitales se interrumpen
eso qué significa no es tiempo de
digerir alimentos no es tiempo de
generar anticuerpos no es tiempo mujeres
de ovular ese no es tiempo de eso es
tiempo de huir
esa misma reacción igualita
no sucede si estamos acostados en
nuestra cama
con la luz apagada temblando por los
leones imaginarios que van a venir a
devorarnos
porque el cerebro no reconoce el uno o
el otro no diferencias y ese león es
real o es imaginario
y lo que sucede en nuestro cuerpo es lo
mismo
por eso nos enfermamos
y esa de alguna manera es la sombra que
tiene el miedo
entonces qué es lo que tenemos que hacer
si va a estar ahí siempre si no se va a
desaparecer para algunas cosas nos sirve
para otras cosas no tenemos que
encontrar su justo volumen ese es el
reto encontrarle ese volumen al miedo
y para mí la fórmula
ha sido una pequeñita y se las quiero
compartir hoy y esa fórmula tiene que
ver con aquí mando yo
aquí mando yo
tenemos en promedio entre 50 y 60 mil
pensamientos al día literal de manera
literal oigan entre 50 y 60 mil
pensamientos al día
que nos decimos
que nos estamos diciendo
esos pensamientos además no pueden ser
simultáneos
esta es la loca de la casa' cita está
atada está pensamientos todo el tiempo
pero uno tras de otro no simultáneos
eso qué quiere decir que cuando estamos
pensando en problemas no podemos pensar
en soluciones
tenemos que pensar en una cosa o en la
otra entonces a esos miedos a esos
pensamientos la justa medida aquí mando
yo
es súper importante que podamos
encaminar nuestros pensamientos
positivos miren las personas que
triunfan no triunfan por el tipo de
pensamientos que tienen sobre el éxito
triunfan por el tipo de pensamientos que
tienen sobre el fracaso
eso qué quiere decir lo más importante
de todos
fracasan los proyectos no las personas
fracaso mi emprendimiento fracaso mi
idea fracaso mi iniciativa no fracase yo
es muy diferente si nos tomamos estos
errores esas equivocaciones como
fracasos propios lo que está fracasando
es la idea que importa eso no lo tengo
porqué esconder no lo tengo porqué negar
no me tengo por qué sentir avergonzado
no me tengo por que fustigar
no tengo por qué buscar culpables en
otros ya está fracaso esa idea tengo
otras tengo miles esa es la diferencia
de pensamiento
yo tengo también otra palabrita que me
ayuda cuando se me está subiendo de
volumen ese miedo
y esa palabrita es una palabra poderoso
aunque
aunque es una palabra que permite que el
miedo esté conmigo miren que no se trata
de vencerlo derrotarlo porque no es
verdad no se van no se van
aunque tenga miedo lo voy a hacer
aunque me preocupe el que dirán lo voy a
intentar aunque fracase esa idea valdrá
la pena haberla hecho
aunque es una palabra que nos empoderan
que nos ayuda para poder seguir adelante
yo sé que todos aquí tienen metas
tenemos metas sueños yo desde ya les voy
a decir lo que va a pasar con esas metas
lo que va a pasar
tiene que ver con la negociación que
hagamos entre nuestros miedos y nuestras
ganas
si tenemos unos miedos muy grandes muy
elevados con un volumen muy fuerte y
unas ganas pequeñitas hasta ahí va a
llegar si medianamente logramos combatir
ese tema posiblemente vamos a obtener
alguno que otro
triunfo de nuestra meta si tenemos más
ganas que miedos
vamos a sacar adelante nuestros
proyectos es así de fácil
y todos aquí en esta sala tenemos
experiencias en los que ya hemos vivido
eso por ejemplo la maternidad
teníamos miedo cuando nos dieron esos
pedacitos
y unas ganas enormes
de que salieran adelante y ahí con miedo
nos fuimos para la casa y con más ganas
lo logramos en algún estudio que hemos
hecho teníamos miedo de arrancar
y con miedo pero con más ganas que miedo
logramos sacarlo adelante
todos tenemos casos de éxito en nuestra
vida personal que nos muestran que esa
negociación si es posible
pero tenemos que tener mucho cuidado con
lo que nos decimos aquí mando yo
quiero dejarles una frase muy linda para
terminar
parafraseando a eric fromm dice yo soy
yo no lo que tengo yo soy yo no lo que
pierdo
muchas gracias